the latest big twist in the story is the
Congressional testimony of Devin Archer
who was a business partner of Hunter
Biden who has said that Joe Biden would
be on as many as 20 I think Business
Schools under Biden was making with
various often foreign people that he was
doing business dealings with and Joe
Biden was vice president at the time
and therefore even if he didn't say
anything even if there's no evidence of
him saying anything that might have been
inappropriate the very fact that he was
on those calls is pretty significant to
sit not and I think no amount of kind of
democratic poo pooing of it can can make
that go away
yeah it certainly shows that uh 100
Biden's intention uh was to flaunt his
access to his father to make him look
like an attractive business partner
often from people who were seeking a
favorable reception in Washington DC